in the last video we introduced you to
the derivative property right over here
that if my function is equal to some
constant that the derivative is going to
be zero at any X and we made a graphical
argument and we also use the definition
of limits to feel good about that
now now let's give a few more of these
properties and these are core properties
as you throughout the rest of your
calculus life your career you will be
using some combination of these
properties to find derivatives so it's
good to one know about them and then to
feel good that they're actually true so
the second one is if my function f of X
is equal to some constant times another
function G of X well then the derivative
of f of X is going to be equal to that
same constant let me do it that same
constant times the derivative of G of X
and once again maybe we could make
actually we could make a graphical
argument for why that is true it's going
this is going to multiply the the slope
is one way to think about it but it's
easier to make an algebraic argument
just using frankly we could use either
one of these definitions for the
derivative I'll use the one on the right
because it feels more general although
you could say well this is true for a
what X could be any a but I'll just use
the one on the right so if we want to
find F prime of X F prime of X using
this definition we know we know whoops
my pen doesn't work F prime of X is
going to be equal to the limit as X as H
approaches 0 I'm using that definition
of f of X plus h minus f of X all of
that over all of that over H well what
is f of X plus h so this is the limit as
H approaches 0 f of X plus h is K times
G of X plus h minus f of X well that's
just K G of X K G of X all of that over
H and then you can factor the K out this
is going to be equal to the limit as H
approaches 0 of K times G of
X plus h minus G of X all of that over H
all I did is I factored that K out and
we know from our limit properties that
this is the same thing as K times the
limit as H approaches 0 of G of X plus h
minus G of X all of that over H and of
course all of this business right over
there
that is just G prime of X so this is
equal to K times G prime of X and I know
what you might be thinking well hey this
feels like it was probably going to be
true so I just assumed it was true but
you can't just assume that and I will
sometimes you can you know when you're
first trying to get your head around it
you can tell how this seems like a
reasonable thing but in math we like to
really know that it is true otherwise we
will build all sorts of conclusions
based on unsound foundations this allows
us to ensure that look this is something
that we can do so this is it's good to
go through what might feel like a little
bit of work to get to this conclusion
now let's do the third property the
third property is the idea that if I
have some function that's the sum or the
difference of two other functions so G
of X and let's see I'm using H a lot so
H let's say let's say I don't know J of
X I don't know J oh yes sure why not J
back you don't see a lot of J of X is
out there well then well then F prime of
X is going to be equal to G prime of X
plus J prime of X and this would also
been true if this instead of being a
positive here if this was a negative or
this instead of addition if this was
subtraction if you're the sum or
difference of two functions and your
derivative is going to be the sum or the
difference of their derivatives and once
again we can just go to the limit the
definition of f prime of X so f prime of
X is going to be equal to the limit as H
approaches zero of f of X plus h but
what is f of X plus h well that's G of X
plus h
plus J of X plus h so that's f of X plus
h minus f of X so f of X is G of X G of
X plus J of X plus J of X notice this is
f of X plus h minus f of X we're going
to put all of that over H so we can put
all of that all of that over H well what
is that equal to well we can just
rearrange what we see on top here this
is equal to the limit as H approaches
zero well let's see all the mentions of
G of X I'm going to put up front so G of
X plus h minus G of X plus J of X plus h
minus J of X and then all of that I
could write it I could write it like
this all of that over H or I could
that's the same thing as this over H
Plus that over H and once again we know
from our limit properties that that is
the exact same thing as the limit as H
approaches 0 of G of X plus h minus G of
X all of that over h plus the limit as H
approaches 0 of J of X plus h minus J of
X all of that over H and this right over
here that is the definition of G prime
of X and this right over here is J prime
J prime of X and we're done and if this
instead of a positive if this was
instead of addition if this was
subtraction well then that subtraction
would carry through and then instead of
addition here we would have subtraction
so hopefully this makes you feel good
about these properties the properties of
themselves are somewhat straightforward
you could probably guess that at them
but it's nice to use the definition of
our derivatives to actually feel feel
that they are very good conclusions to
make